il est un peu moins de 6h30 à moscou
lorsque vladimir poutine prend la parole
en direct à la télévision le ton est
grave et l'annoncent redouté dans le
monde entier
[Musique]
après six bouts de
ipo attaqué
et je nie calysto une opération
militaire lancée en ukraine dans le
donbass plus précisément là même où
vladimir poutine a reconnu
l'indépendance de deux régions
sécessionnistes lundi le président russe
a également appelé les soldats ukrainien
a déposé leurs armes du côté de kiev
volodymyr zelensky en appel à la
population russe et est ce que le rocker
bruce iii cynique roach a dit ça y est
ça la met pas
anodin ce taux
soit le russe qui ya créé trois
visites tolkas à 3 plusieurs explosions
ont été entendues ce matin en ukraine
dans l'est comme accra matt horth qu
kharkiv ou encore marioupol mais aussi
dans la ville portuaire d'odessa et dans
la capitale kiev pour washington il ne
fait aucun doute qu'une guerre a été
lancé le président poutine a choisi de
lancer une guerre prémédité qui
entraînera des souffrances et des pertes
humaines catastrophique la russie seuls
les responsables des morts et des
destructions que cette attaque
provoquera les etats-unis leur allié
partenaires répondront de manière unie
et décisive le monde demandera des
comptes à la russie
mercredi soir le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu s'est réuni en urgence le
secrétaire général des nations unies
s'est directement adressée à vladimir
poutine
ce top trumps from the dukes give peace
a chance to many people worldwide
l'onu dépose ce jeudi un projet de
résolution condamnant la russie
est attendu vendredi
et gauthier